il est de rouge fluo moyens il a une
forme régulière un épiderme lice il est
beau à voir
c'est le piment d'espelette on est au
marché jean-talon pensant faisait
demander beaucoup du piment girls un
possible de cultiver du piment
d'espelette ailleurs qu'au pays basque
en france c'est une appellation
d'origine protégée par l'union
européenne depuis 2012
par contre michel et victoire palardy
cultive depuis sept ans du piment gorria
de tipis ce pôle est il ya eu nos amis
qui connaissait quelqu'un qui a possédé
puis qui nous en a amené un lot un bon
lot
quand on s'est dit on va l'essayer pour
le chef grégory paul c'est un
assaisonnement dont il ne peut se passer
quand on a décidé de faire une petite
pas rien d'acquis et va être un mix de
fruits de mer grillé à la plancha qui
vont accompagner notre confie de piment
d'espelette ferait plonger les
coquillages sur la plaque
si le flétan c'est très important de
mettre le piment d'espelette soit en fin
de cuisson fait mais pas l'utiliser dans
la cuisson pas le faire caraméliser
parce qu'il va brûler de suite on va
perdre tout le pare-feu et ça se sent
des piments que vous avez laissé
échapper c'est ça exactement en fait
c'est le piment quand il est frais on
l'a cuisiné avec un petit peu de tomates
oignons huile d'olive
[Musique]
je
allez un petit peu de piment d'espelette
tout ceci
faut être généreux et le piment
d'espelette sécu c'est le produit qui
pas forcément très épicé et qui est très
chaud mais l'huile d'olive vierge est un
petit peu de jus de citron
je pense comment pouvoir les déguster ça
ensemble
grégory sait comment attirer notre oeil
et si je me suis amusé avec quelques
légumes avec une trempette une base de
yogourt piment d'espelette frais et sec
il a invité son ami pierre importateur
de vins et basques de par son père pour
célébrer le piment d'espelette
la particularité du piment d'espelette
c'est que quand on cuisine gris
évidemment il ya des sucres qui vont
sortir automatiquement et le piment
d'espelette ça n'est pas moi c'est pas
un canapé nyon s'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose qui va exploser deux on va
dire de force qui va vous qui va vous
ont bu la bouche et des papilles c'est
un pilote qui va tout simplement avoir
un goût un petit peu poivrot n'est pas
trop et qui ensuite va avoir une épice a
pas pire que le poivre les palardy sont
parmi les plus importants producteurs de
piment gorria au québec
je le fais sécher une fois au fond leur
cette famille complètement le séchage
personnages plus loin il faut huit kilos
de piment pour produire un kilo de
poudre
mais le sait ce que vous avez utilisé
pour préparer ses plats où vous avez
utilisé le piment tous bords y a moi
j'utilise rapidement gurria parce que on
est au québec
or al aryane c'est en amérique du sud
que l'on trouve les plus anciennes
racines de piment d'espelette et ces
deux là aussi que nous vient la main
d'oeuvre pour le cultiver
lahoud south x men
[Musique]
pierre vesperini a choisi des vins
rouges pour accompagner le festin ce que
génial là dedans c'est que le poivron va
permettre de boire du rouge et non pas
du bluff c'est que l'intéressé d'avoir
des vins épicés ou des vins doux et
soyeux à boire c'est pas compliqué le
rincer on aime ou on n'aime pas bien
avant de boire du vin rouge avec le
piment pierre en consommer comme remède
aux maux ma grand mère c'est l'hiver à
l'école elle me faisait un chocolat
chaud quand elle savait que j'avais là
là on va dire un petit peu mal le fond
de gorge
mc toujours au goût du bima mais moi
aussi elle faisait un petit chocolat
chaud avec du piment d'espelette pour
guillet tenir ce repas ont parfait
moussy les desserts avec le pima il ya
comme la touch de poivrons mais tout
doux ses pieds l'omx est vraiment en
fait surtout venance la framboise qui va
prendre un petit peu aussi je ne fume le
fruit en goûte à chocolat qu'on touche
au mérite au 1
[Musique]